I think one of the most important things
in life is finding mentors with over 3/4
the rookie sensation for Lightning
McQueen his mentor is doc had said I
would give anything to talk to him right
now and the lessons that he taught
applies to the journey that lightning
McQueen's on I'd saw something in you
that you don't even see in yourself I've
been lucky to have great mentors in
different areas and different things
that I've sort of pursued for me it was
James L Brooks who has such an
unbelievable resume with the Simpsons
and Mary Tyler Moore so to have somebody
like that bring us out to Los Angeles
made all the difference in our lives the
first thing I did on television was a
Matlock and Andy Griffith taught me how
to be a television actor I had no clue
as a stand-up comic my mentor was an
actor who I worked with and had it not
been for his expertise his advice I
wouldn't be sitting here with you today
my high school drama teachers they
nurtured me and they would take me to
compete nationally in the summer on the
free time they made me who I am for me I
think about as women who kind of paved
the path before me my own boss at ABC a
Shonda Rhimes through their huge role
model for me oh my god prowl you got it
you
[Applause]
you